[Musique]
1ère d'extrême orient a franchi les
remparts du château de la madeleine à
chevreuse l'inde la thématique du
spectacle de l'association manie
croiserez création équestre une
représentation avec lui chevaux en
costume ont fait naître des sourires sur
le visage des enfants
c'est une animation qui les gens nous
suivent depuis des années chaque année
savent qu'on est là ils reviennent ils
veulent voir le spectacle va le voir les
chevaux ils veulent monter dessus
un événement organisé dans le cadre des
virades de l'espoir la journée nationale
de lutte contre la mucoviscidose
une habitude pour l'association de
participer à cette cause je trouve que
c'est une très bonne initiative et ça
permet par le jeu et l'amusement des
enfants de rapporter de l'argent à une
association qui le méritent donc je suis
très contente que ça existe il faut
tirer ailleurs la gauche et pour plus
d'ailleurs loi faut tirer
des vérités de l'animation c'est par des
passer un bon moment avec les enfants et
pour eux c'est aussi une façon de
découvrir voilà un cheval un tueur c'est
très bien les virades de l'espoir au
château de la madeleine ont permis de
récolter plus de 6000 euros soit près de
1900 euros de plus par rapport à l'an
dernier